MCCORMICK: I was 18 and I was hunting for the first
time on my own.
It was quiet and misty, and the air — it's crisp.
The tiny, yellow birch leaves are rustling.
Suddenly out of the brush steps that bull
moose.
That's when I took a few deep breaths and took the shot.
I remember just thanking our creator for the
gift of the meat
and just, feeling like
this is something that has given its life
so that I can live, so that my family can live.
For as long as they’ve lived on the shores of Lake Superior,
the Ojibwe or Anishinaabe people have revered
and depended on the moose.
GAWBOY: Game pieces were carved from the antlers,
rattles were made from the hooves,
warm stockings were made of the hocks of the moose,
moose hair embroidery made beautiful clothing.
The relationship to the moose is almost mythic.
But a few years ago, something strange started
happening.
The moose began to disappear from the landscape.
"Minnesota’s moose population fell for the
fourteenth straight year."
"An alarming decline."
"A growing mystery that has scientists baffled
and on the hunt for answers."
"The moose of Minnesota are dying, and
no one knows why."
TIBBETTS: The Ojibwe people have lived along
these banks forever.
MCCORMICK: It’s just a really unique place that we
call home: the most north eastern point of
Minnesota, bordered by Canada and also by
Lake Superior.
This area has a relatively harsh climate.
About mid-October to about early May, we typically
have snow on the ground.
MOORE: It's a difficult place to live and so
subsisting off of the species that are present here
really requires some effort.
MCCORMICK: My family has always harvested deer, moose.
It means something to us, it's not a sportsman
type of a hunt.
It's not a "let's find out who has the biggest
set of antlers," you know.
It's just a very special thing.
TIBBETTS: This last year, I went around and delivered
these baskets of moose meat to my brother,
my niece, my sister.
When you’re able to provide for your family yourself,
I mean, that’s what we’re really put here—I think—to do.
You know, to take care of each other.
It's part of the reason why we
care so much about our moose population is
because we want to continue to subsistence
hunt for future generations.
But scientists were worried that hunting
might be part of the problem.
MOORE: It was our belief that human hunting was
the primary cause really affecting mortality in moose.
That hypothesis made sense.
White settlers and their descendants had hunted the states native
elk and caribou out of existence.
MOORE: So when we saw this decline,
it was a very immediate decision that we
need to understand what's going on
and if that decline can be reversed.
To figure out what was happening, Seth and
his team started going out in helicopters.
When they spotted a moose, they’d
give it a tranquilizer.
Then, hike to the moose, and place
a GPS collar around its neck.
After a quick shot to reverse the tranquilizer
the moose would be on its way.
MOORE: And when the moose stopped moving
for a period greater than six hours
essentially it sends a mortality signal to the satellite
and then the satellite sends a text to my phone.
And when we get there, typically we'll find a dead moose.
We cut open the moose and take samples
from every single organ system in the moose
and we send those off to a diagnostic lab.
And the majority of the time, they can tell
us what was wrong with that moose.
To understand these results, there’s something
else you need to know about this part of the world:
MCCORMICK: Our winters have changed.
Snow drifts as tall as the doorway—the last
time that happened in my lifetime was 1992.
MOORE: Our average snow depth in early spring has
declined by about 70 percent and our temperatures
have increased by about five degrees Fahrenheit
on average as well.
The biggest moose killer that Seth and his
team discovered was the brainworm.
It's a parasitethat lives in the brains
of white-tailed deer, but doesn’t harm them.
Typically, deer and moose don't share
the same habitat.
With their lighter coats and shorter legs,
deer tend to thrive in places with warmer winters.
But in the last 30 years, rising winter temperatures
have lured white-tailed deer
from the southern part of Minnesota
into the state's northern reaches.
Right into the moose's habitat.
And the deer bring the brainworm with them.
Its eggs hatch in the deer’s feces, then slugs
eat the newly hatched larvae,
and climb up onto plants.
Moose eat those plants, and the slugs, and the worms
which end up in their brains.
It tends to tunnel around looking for
the right habitat for it
which is a deer's brain.
And it's those tunnels that caused the neurological
damage
They keep their head tilted and they walk
in circles and
eventually they just starve to death.
When warmer winters bring white-tailed deer
further north, that causes another problem
for the moose: wolves.
MOORE: The wolf population in northern Minnesota
has increased dramatically.
Like most predators, wolves follow their main
food source.
MOORE: When the moose are giving birth,
moose calves are actually the easiest thing
on the landscape to eat.
MOORE: We're losing 70 or 80 percent, each year,
within the first two weeks of life.
MOORE: And that's just too high a rate of mortality
for the population to replace itself.
Warmer winters amplify a third major threat
to the moose: infestations by winter ticks.
These parasites spend the entire winter attached
to the skin of the moose.
Then, in the early spring, they drop off to
lay their eggs.
MOORE: If they drop off between, say,
February and April,
if there is is deep snow on the ground,
it essentially kills them off.
Enough ticks survive to jump on the moose
and start the cycle again, but enough die
so that the moose aren’t overwhelmed.
But in recent decades, that deep spring snow
hasn’t been there to kill off a portion of the ticks.
MOORE: So the winter ticks are hitting the ground,
they're all surviving.
MOORE: Their eggs are surviving.
When winter comes around, all those surviving
ticks attach themselves to the moose.
MOORE: Sometimes you'll see a moose with a hundred
thousand ticks on it.
MOORE: They aren't eating well because the ticks
are so uncomfortable they’re constantly
just trying to scrape them off of their body
and they end up starving to death or
becoming anemic.
MOORE: They’re called ghost moose because
they’re missing 60 to 70 percent of their hair.
MOORE: It's just bare skin.
MOORE: I mean, it’s horrifying looking.
MOORE: The moose population is declining directly as
a consequence of climate change.
MOORE: There's just no reason to stop the subsistence hunt.
People always talk about Indians living
right on the edge of starvation
or on the edge of survival.
GAWBOY: But not only did they provide themselves
with this great diet,
they had time to decorate even down to little babies.
GAWBOY: Little babies' outfits were beautifully decorated.
I mean, who knows that these days?
GAWBOY: Every time I think about the Ojibwe people through time,
I just kind of shake my head and I thought,
why don't people know this?
Four hundred years ago, the Ojibwe lands stretched
for nearly 2,000 square miles,
from Lake Ontario all the way to the Northern Great Plains.
It’s where they hunted, fished, and harvested.
Where they danced, raised their children,
and buried their loved ones.
European settlers wanted that land.
To farm.
To log.
To mine.
To drill for oil and gas.
In a few hundred years, the descendents of
those settlers helped build an economy around
extracting, refining, and burning that oil and gas,
pushing up global temperatures,
altering ecosystems, and changing the life
cycles of species large and small.
Today, the Ojibwe homelands are a fraction
of what they once were.
But their culture has endured.
TIBBETTS: The resiliency of native peoples is—
it can't be questioned, you know?
We're still here.
We've always just felt more connected to
our environment. How we treat the Earth.
You know, I always wondered, growing up, if the people
would've taken the time to learn more about
the Anishinaabe.
You know, what would this country look like?
I think it would be a lot stronger.